[Applause]
the war in ukraine is the best thing
that could have happened to china to the
war in ukraine 90 of its houses are
damaged by air from the sea and most
brutally by land that the conflict is
taking longer than moscow anticipated
and they blame one person vladimir putin
while the people in ukraine are
suffering and the world is distracted by
all the violence and nuclear threats
china is sitting back
silently observing
how does the west and nato react to such
an invasion which countries might
intervene with military forces and could
sanctions actually hurt the economy
this is china's chance to learn from
putin's mistakes and perfect this master
plan the unification of mainland china
with taiwan
taiwan is a province of china are you
willing to get involved militarily to
defend taiwan if it comes to that yes
that's the commitment we made
for decades china has been working hard
to become the next undisputed superpower
they've emerged as the world's second
largest economy right behind their
number one enemy the united states
they've built up a respectable military
force for advanced weapon systems but
there's just one thing that has always
slipped their grasp
bringing taiwan back under beijing's
control
why
you keep hearing about taiwan but why is
china willing to risk it all for this
tiny island what is so special about it
what's the big deal and will taiwan be
the target of the world's next invasion
china could have similar plans for
taiwan
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime of my team subscribe for more if
you want to win a thousand dollars cash
starting right now we're picking a
random instagram follower every single
week to win you just have to be
following me at jaketren just got this
new handle and you're automatically
entered watch out for fake accounts i
will never message you asking for money
and this is the complicated history of
taiwan
[Music]
[Applause]
if you invest in crypto or stocks
wouldn't it be nice to see exactly what
the people you look up to invest in
after all people's actions what they
invest in speak a lot louder than words
what they tell people they should invest
in this used to be impossible but that's
where public comes in public is a social
investing app where you can easily
invest in stocks etfs and crypto with
any amount of money and millions of
people are already taking advantage of
it public is a total game changer
because you can follow other investors
right in the app to see what they invest
in imagine how much valuable information
you can learn by peering into the minds
of other successful business people and
seeing exactly what they're investing in
this used to be impossible and what
people invested in was a closely guarded
secrets but not anymore thanks to public
i'm on public too you can follow me at
jake tran and what's great about public
is that they always put their investors
first unlike other investment apps
public will never sell your trades to
market makers and your trades are rented
directly to exchanges the public app is
free to use and there are no commissions
on stator stock trades and is backed by
investors like will smith the
chainsmokers and tony hawk public has
thousands of stocks and etfs to choose
from and over 30 different cryptos like
bitcoin cordano and ethereum plus you
can buy slices of a stock etf or crypto
instead of a full share so you can get
started no matter what your budget is
and if you go to public.com jaketrain
and create an account you'll get a free
stock worth anywhere from three dollars
to a thousand dollars that's public.com
to get a free stock with the link below
thanks to public for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
up to the late 19th century china's qing
dynasty ruled over both mainland china
and taiwan but then the japanese came
along the japanese were feeling
ambitious at the time and had a whiff of
imperialism so they wanted to expand
their empire
and one of their targets taiwan so in
1895 the japanese army landed near key
lung on the northern coast of taiwan
and the japanese invasion of taiwan
began the taiwanese army fought back
with all they had and even resorted to
guerilla tactics to slow down the enemy
but it wasn't enough
after five months of bloodshed the
taiwanese waved the white flag and for
the next 50 years taiwan was a part of
the japanese empire
but empires come and go and after japan
was defeated during world war ii taiwan
came back under the control of the
chinese but at that time a civil war was
escalating in china the communists led
by mao zedong were fighting against the
nationalists over who was going to rule
china and slowly but surely the
communists were gaining more and more
control over the mainland
in january 1949 a brutal guerrilla
warfare campaign brought beijing under
communist control and by august the
communist party's own army the people's
liberation army or pla had gained a
foothold over almost all of mainland
china battle after battle forced the
nationalists to retreat further into
southeastern china on october 1st 1949
mao zedong declared victory and china
was now known as the people's republic
of china or prc
[Music]
[Applause]
china had officially fallen to the
communists and the communist revolution
has succeeded
but the nationalists wouldn't give up
that easily even though they were
defeated on the mainland they would
rather die than live under a communist
regime
they had been backed into the literal
corner of southeastern china and the
only place they had to go was to cross
the taiwan strait and retreat to taiwan
so over the course of the next four
months some 2 million soldiers officers
and many civilians and refugees made
their way to taiwan
they saw it as their chance to regroup
recover gain their strength back and
come up with a new plan to take back the
mainland
so even though the communists won the
war the conflict was far from over
[Music]
after a few failed attempts to regain
some land on the mainland the
nationalists realized that facing the
communists head-on was pointless the
communists had grown too strong and they
too weak it was time for a change in
strategy so they thought to themselves
fine we'll let these communists do
whatever they want on the mainland but
taiwan
we'll build our empire here we'll build
the real china
[Applause]
so they set up a brand new government a
regime in exile so to speak and went to
work
at the time there was practically
nothing in taiwan so the people were
poor and struggling to survive but they
were alive and ready to build something
of their own
by the 50s and 60s taiwan was relying
heavily on economic aid from the u.s but
that was all set to change the island
wanted to stand on its own two feet so
it began to produce and export cheap
consumer goods for the world it started
with the basics like sugar tea rice and
textiles and as a result taiwan's
economy started to grow stronger and
stronger as they traded more with the us
their economic ties with the u.s grew
stronger and stronger until eventually
they became one of the us's biggest
trading partners to counter the threat
of china the us eventually started
selling billions worth of weapon systems
to taiwan's military even though china
strongly disapproved
but late 1980s taiwan shifted from a
one-party dictatorship to a democracy
and people started to enjoy more and
more freedom while china had to watch
from afar as this little island got
wealthier and more independent by the
day
but then in the 1990s taiwan made a
decision that would change its fate
forever
they dove head first into the
semiconductor industry and they started
dominating it
today almost everything is powered by
taiwan's high-end ships from smartphones
to high-end military defense systems
including the ones by the us
so whoever controls taiwan would also
control the advanced chip industry which
would inadvertently be the ultimate
position of power in the 21st century in
china they were fuming watching all of
this transpire
[Music]
china's port cities like hong kong and
shanghai connect china's economy to the
rest of the world but if you want to get
out into the pacific thousands of
smaller and larger islands stand in your
way from the japanese archipelago
to taiwan the philippines and sumatra
navigating around all these islands
makes your export business a lot more
difficult especially since these islands
are largely under us influence
since the 1950s the u.s has been working
to bring the so-called first island
chain under the control imagine if the
u.s had a bunch of islands up and down
its east and west coast and all of them
were controlled by china at any moment
china could choose to block off the us
from the rest of the world and since
most trade comes through the oceans a
blockade like this would suffocate
america in a matter of weeks that's the
position china is in right now with
these first island chains under
america's influence it's a strategic
nightmare for them by taking over taiwan
china would break the encirclement in
half and gain direct access to the
pacific that's the strategic reason for
wanting taiwan
but there's also something much deeper
at play here over the decades taiwan has
developed into a proud independent
country with its own identity the people
in taiwan don't see themselves as
chinese citizens anymore they are proud
taiwanese people now they have a booming
economy a democratic system good
healthcare a weird concept called
freedom of speech and they're ready to
defend their precious island with all
they've got
this represents a fundamental problem
for china what would it mean for the
citizens of china if they saw they could
have just as much if not more prosperity
than what the chinese government offers
while having more freedom after all it's
not like the people of taiwan are
fundamentally different than the people
of china both populations come from
mainland china except one is westernized
has more freedom and in a lot of ways a
lot more prosperity what if china didn't
need a surveillance state what if life
could go on without the legitimate
threat of getting kidnapped by the
government what if the government
couldn't just shut down their business
and throw them in jail whenever they
pleased just what if
that is the problem with taiwan taiwan's
success is a threat to everything the
chinese government stands for it
threatens their power it threatens to
infect their population with the idea of
freedom but beijing would never admit to
that so they stick to their old claim
that taiwan is nothing more than lost
territory a part of united glorious
china that mainland china holds a
historical claim over taiwan that taiwan
is rightfully theirs and that is only
fair that you take back what was once
yours right but why is china hesitating
after all china's armed forces already
dwarfed those of taiwan and china has
advanced weapons most countries can only
dream of but even though taiwan's
military may not be a match for china's
with the us by their side taiwan is
certain that they can fend off an
invasion
so as of right now no chinese leader has
dared to take the risk but now it seems
like beijing may be finally ready to
take that risk
[Music]
since 2016 beijing has been turning up
the heat on taiwan their goal to wear
them down by any means and make the
people realize hmm maybe it's better to
reunite with the mainland instead of
getting crushed by it and beijing
doesn't shy away from using the dirtiest
tactics in the book for one the
taiwanese government faces thousands of
cyber attacks every single day beijing
has put china's best hackers on the job
and the task is clear to infiltrate the
government and get as much intel as
possible if you know exactly how your
enemy's defense systems work you can
find a way to destroy them if you know
what your enemy knows about you you can
change your strategy and hit them with a
surprise attack the more you know the
better your chances of gaining the upper
hand but beijing is also big on
controlling the media and spreading
misinformation in the 2020 election
china spread misinformation to drive
taiwan's current president out of office
a divided country is a weak country and
if you can't pull off a successful
invasion maybe you can sow enough
division and destroy the system from
within or maybe to get a pro-chinese
leader installed much like what the us
does but that's only one part of china's
strategy to bring taiwan to its knees
for years china has been spending
hundreds of billions of dollars on its
military it's beijing's goal to have the
most powerful military forces and
weapons systems in the world so even if
the us steps in china's military could
handle it they've built up their marine
forces to five times its previous size
and they are working on advanced missile
technology that even the u.s is afraid
of
u.s officials tonight closely monitoring
china's missile program following a
report of a possibly ominous missile
test an article by the financial times
said that china tested a nuclear-capable
hypersonic missile that circled the
globe before speeding towards its target
demonstrating an advanced space
capability that caught u.s intelligence
by surprise and to make sure china could
handle a war on several fronts china's
military has been practicing missile
attacks on fake us warships practice
makes perfect after all and if china
reaches a point where they're no longer
afraid of a u.s military strike all bets
are off
beijing also has a clear warning to
taiwan's allies in a defense document it
says that china's military would
resutely defeat anyone attempting to
separate taiwan from china in the
meantime china's military has been
trying to intimidate taiwan into
submission they've been sending warships
through the taiwan strait in a show of
force and for the last two years china's
fighter jets were flying near and over
taiwan on a daily basis
on may 6 this year china sent 18
warplanes including fighters and bombers
into taiwan's air defense zone besides
keeping taiwan's defense on constant
alert it's also a great psychological
tactic when your enemies surround you 24
7 from all sides never showing any signs
of weakness and taiwan is taking these
threats quite seriously so they are
preparing for war
in china's eyes a military invasion
probably wouldn't be their first choice
but if they can't subvert taiwan back
under their control peacefully an
invasion at the right time may be their
only option but even with an impressive
military and high-end weapon systems it
won't be that easy
[Music]
when you look at taiwan versus china on
a map it almost looks like a no-brainer
yeah this would be a walk in the park
for china but there's more than meets
the eye and invading taiwan may be the
greatest military challenge in history
unlike ukraine taiwan is an island so
you don't have thousands of miles of
shared border from where you can invade
your armed forces need to cross about
100 miles of ocean before the actual
invasion begins your invading force
would be exposed for several hours and a
lot can go wrong during that time taiwan
and its allies might come at you with
guerrilla-like attacks sinking dozens of
warships in the process so before you
even reach taiwan's shore you're already
exhausted confused and demoralized
we all learned in war 101 that the
invading army must be at least three
times bigger than the defending army so
even though taiwan has only about 170
000 active troops china might need
between 400 000 to 1 million troops for
an invasion that's a lot of troops then
you need hundreds of ships to transport
these men and hundreds of jets to
protect them living quarters food
supplies for each men
there is a lot of infrastructure that
goes into a war aside from the weapons
and the us would most likely notice such
a military buildup just like they did
with ukraine it would be a logistical
nightmare and since the chinese military
has practically no combat experience it
would get very bloody and then there's
the next little challenge you have to
overcome taiwan's limited landing
options the eastern part of taiwan is
mostly mountains and cliffs so forget
about landing on that side and on the
west side there are only a few places
where china's troops could actually land
and your timing would have to be perfect
you need to hit the beaches and ports
simultaneously to overwhelm your enemy
then you would have to fight like hell
for every inch of land while deadly
counter fire would pour down on you from
all sides
besides most of taiwan's chip facilities
are in those areas and destroying them
would be a huge loss for china
they call it taiwan's silicon shield
their superior chip technology is simply
too valuable even for china to destroy
so they have to think twice about what
they want to blow up in that area
there are also taiwan's nearby allies
you have to think about
okinawa is less than an hour's flight
away from taiwan and there are us
warplanes and 20 000 marines waiting to
join the fight
japan has been in talks with taiwan as
well they are worried that if taiwan
falls japan's outlying islands could be
next so japan's armed forces may join
the fight as well
but if all that doesn't stop china and
they still take over taiwan we may see
the beginning of a new world order
the us alliance around the first island
chain would break in half
and china would take full control of the
advanced chip industry putting the
modern world at their mercy
threats like china make it no surprise
that the cyber security field is booming
right now and more important than ever
with an average salary of 96 000 a year
the problem is cyber security can be
very overwhelming to get into you need
computer science fundamentals maybe some
programming algorithm fundamentals it's
a lot and can be very intimidating but
if this is something you think you might
want to get into then i've got the
perfect solution for you brilliant
brilliant is a learning platform that
has courses on all these subjects that i
just mentioned and much more it helps
you learn the stem skills you need to
make a lot of money through entertaining
interactive courses i recommend taking
their computer science learning path
that would give you a great foundation
and within this learning path there's a
computer science fundamentals course an
algorithm fundamentals course and much
more and if you start and you don't
think it's for you well don't worry
because they have a ton of other stem
learning paths you can choose from the
great thing about brilliant is that it's
helped over 11 million people truly
understand stem concepts instead of just
memorizing them like they have us do in
school so if you're ready to get your
foundation in these profitable skills
you can get started for free by visiting
brilliant.org jake tran with the link
below the first 200 people to sign up
will get 20 off brilliant annual premium
subscription that's brilliant.org that's
jake tran for 20 off today thanks to
brilliant for sponsoring this video
[Music]
what's up guys hope you guys enjoy the
video and if you are new here we make
documentaries just like this one every
single week on money power and crime for
free so if you enjoyed this one click
the subscribe button below you can
follow me on instagram jaytrend.io i
only have one account and i will never
message you asking for money so watch
out for fake accounts but that's gonna
wrap it up stay dangerous out there and
i'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you